sono felicissimo di poter iniziare
questo complesso quello a tutti i
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
savocese fatto se ho fatto line trovò
dire che questo è un bel film ma proprio
bel video siamo su talking over it già
il nome
partiamo credo che conosciate tutti il
gioco a cui si riferisce sta roba
getting over it l'hanno fatto dove tu
controlli una pallina da gol a tu fai
schifo schifo però in teoria dovresti
usare st pallina da golf e arrivare in
diversi punti ben al di qua devo andare
devo andare a destra avrebbero non
potevo superare il che ne so io
perfetto la cosa più divertente di tutto
ciò è questo gioco l'ho pagato 5 euro 5
euro che poteva spendere per andare a
[ __ ] cordisco dello starting over ma
pure la narrazione del feeling non li
carbon intensity del mondo gli è
sembrato reggono di katyn gori solo che
queste dal burundi cui di filtri solving
urti e ce l'ho fatta fermento il sito
stai zitto che devo concentrarmi la
parte che non mi piace come una riprova
over the three cioè la cosa veramente
triste è che fa veramente schifo cioè
senso è la versione cinese di di
ticketing ed è difficile uguale quello
che mimì mi sorprende ma io posso dare
più volte alla palla ok no allora faccio
così scusa continua tirelli botte a no
ad un pò cadeo che a top of the stairs
all right ragazzi beh siamo arrivati c'è
un bel punto diretti a per cambiare
linguaggio proprio l'italia proprio il
buco del culo del mondo bene in giappone
c'è ma io voglio sentire tipo parlare in
giapponese e non vale sono semi parla
ancora in in inglese burundiano vale
allora che brutti sti albering
soddisfano e un tè con rain dal team out
in tutto in sé ma è il più bel
giapponese che abbia mai visto è
cambiata è cambiato solo in basso non è
cambiata da tali quando si però
catturare capisco di più così che come
parli di originale chiede castrata in un
albero non cadere giunto in canada
rinaldin food eating spiritoso stai
zitto per cortesia via fametta
il mercato questo se andava ancora più a
sinistra poteva essere grave la
situazione mi fai qui stare zitto per
favore mi dà fastidio bene a questo
volevo destra si sa che non sa cosa fa
ciò che con incredibile vai vai vai vai
madonna bye bye bye bye mezzo perfetto
no no e commerciali voli scusa a devo
prima del sull'albero ok
[Musica]
il problema dell'essere umano in sé non
è tanto allora i giochi di merda noah
tipo getting over non è che finita no
fanno le coppie è capito lo copiano i
giochi delle palle decidono di copiare
altri giochi delle palle è un ciclo di
tre ragazze prima fanno un gioco che
java schifo poi arriva quello peggio
capito ma come youtube prima già
youtuber fanno schifo non puoi che
arriva mette p.zza de jong ragazzi è
veramente molto più difficile di quanto
pensiate credetemi gesù che protesta
racket eccola per bolano porca vacca o
no no no perché capita in tempo perché
perché l'ho scaricato l'ho pagato 5 euro
eva lurida insozzata sera io non è che
abbia tutta questa voglia di perdere la
mia vita io ho degli amici e una
famiglia un cane o un gatto che sono
rispettivamente pietro thomas io gioco a
questo schifo ecc e surreal power che a
tenerife mentre io gioco se merda gioco
di me
siccome siamo tutti uguali in questa
community di youtube laida perché quella
tenerife io gioco a questo schifo in
terra del demonio morto ieri come lo sa
dire ogni volta che sbaglio guardiamo
una storia surreal power che che sa
tenere bene giusto per incazzarmi ancora
di pietro
come avevo fatto quino spiegami nel
mondo dell'universo come come come non
posso non va su lo vedi che non va più
su dico 0 2 batte 2 1 e 2 comma tua
madre ieri non va come avevo fatto prima
non arriva guarda guarda qua seca
seccato minchia di stermino tutti
proprio tutti
tutte le persone che hai anche solo
incrociato per strada per quelle no no
no no non si può piano piano piano piano
piano per l'amor di gesù bambino piano
ok ok è appena uscita una foto sul
profilo a lasciare like io ho messo di
cioccolatini qui al sole e in 20 secondi
si stanno sciogliendo la quanto cardio
fa niente mi sto cominciando bella ciao
perfetto benissimo perfetto piano piano
ma perché che cosa diavolo mi
rappresenta quella roba lì spiegamento
cos'è un pony con i capelli ma cosa che
vi passa per il cervello ma spiegami ok
è già ed è già il punto più avanti in
cui io sia mai arrivato fino adesso
pensate
no non mi mandare i messaggi adesso che
ti devo uccidere alla famiglia perché
adesso tra tutti i momenti di distrarre
in questo momento perché perché tra
tutti i momenti magari da dove potevi
distrarmi adesso che devo saltare
sull'aquila porca vacca che cosa accede
la cosa vuoi mamma cosa c'è mamma di b
ciao lore hai mangiato si si mangia
vacanza mi sta ponendo la camera inoltre
volevo farmi un sondaggio stefano
dovrebbe partire last minute per un
viaggio a carissimo per settimana oppure
no
a voi a nessuno di lavorare la brava un
mese power bravo sì un vero gamer altro
che che vacanze fatti sta roba fatti
fatti quei questa è la mia vacanza si
configura come mi sto abbronzandosi
abbronzato perché lo schermo lo schermo
di computer e una bronzo purtroppo sono
quest'ora sarei carlo conti
[Musica]
vela salvo ti diverti a tenerife pezzo
di me